so so glad I'm so glad that we started
this podcast just now instead of just
five seconds before because I'm just
going to say what he said I'm not gonna
put context around it you go bust in
their mouth and then you tuck your chin
like you're getting ready to take a shot
you look at me I was like why is your
mid conversation I just chimed in at the
very end yeah yeah when I came back from
New York man back from the or it looks
like New York age you yeah five to ten
years yeah yeah any of the light hair on
your nose you're at a Whitehead on your
eyeball what he have to talk about my
Whitehead on my night and why why do you
have asked me at 50 because the heirs of
[ __ ] braces like that they're not
there [ __ ] look man why we talk about
acne and breaks to the fifty it's a
problem and even my own wife in New York
after like four days mile ahead my face
was I didn't I had like sirens I was
like what the [ __ ] is going on with my
face acne my wife cuz you got your skin
is breaking out I go well the air is
horrific it's so hot you walk in you
sweat and be in New York in the
summertime for two weeks is a little
much i mother country jungle never been
happier to get back to LA I was don't
goes damn what happened your face go
concrete jungle
concrete junk now did you sleep three
hours a week I'll be honest with you
last night I drank a little too much
wine and then did your French given up
all night like what the hi I'm after the
problems with my head my head is showing
the signs of my of my behavior last
night in New York and it was a long
don't take a long why did you put your
head outside the subway when you're
right another I got hit with couples
yeah I got hit with some pebbles are you
Casey from the Ninja Turtles like what's
cool about it man well helping my friend
well in a rough time all right and I
feel like my head I feel like my head is
wrapped in a wet towel right now it
didn't you know I mean like I feel like
somebody stuffed a wet towel in my brain
like I feel a little bit like a little
heavy little groggy oh yeah because
don't do smog from 1 million people and
a half a mile radius that it's it's that
it's being on a subway and then people
are sweating and then a sweat kind of
accumulates on the ceiling and it rains
down on you I mean I don't know you just
didn't know subway let's get the tube
it's 90 degrees get a tube I just got
could breathe in my direction everybody
breathe in my direction see this pack of
Sensen sells in so my dick is pushing
against your after that I don't know
we'll be drilling again even then you're
like let's move it here you help for
anything oh yeah hey how about when
we're there with J where I you know I
don't have I'm not like yelling grew up
in New York I'm not very familiar with
these trains alright it's hot as hell
outside right we're waiting for the
train she goes do you know what happen
the other day I want anything like no
one happening us thing got stuck for six
hours no AC people open the windows
trying to breathe fresh air it was bad
like where the [ __ ] did tells you have
an ankle lock did well it back and go
it's gotten better the suburbs gotten
way better back in the day there always
be just dudes who would ride the subway
in rush hour and they push up against
young lady and just kind of the sort
that happened on those the subway
purpose on WorldStarHipHop that I'm
always watching the subway that's going
from like whatever the train is from the
Bronx to the Brooklyn or whatever the
final yeah technology and so it always
seems fun like there's breakdancing
there's fight yes working every single
time I mean what has cool shoes on the
train Erebor well and usually on subways
almost always you'll be there once a day
somebody will come in he's got a sign
and he's like dressed kind of well and
he's like excuse me ladies and gentlemen
so sorry to take a moment take a minute
of your time I am on the street I had I
do have six kids they all have epilepsy
we are living right now in a hole we
couldn't afford a cardboard box in a
hole we are eating lint we could only
afford lint so if there's anything you
can do
please help we would really appreciate
it it walks around with a cop zoo and
he'll nobody nobody typically will look
at him they won't look at him see
there's always one old lady who's like
she pulls out a tiny shitty coin and
goes getting and he goes god bless you
thank you god bless you
and in the middlee conversation thank
you ladies and gentlemen god bless all
of you regardless of whether or not you
gave me money I want to go I want to
bless all of you my children bless you
my children are hungry once again but it
is fine I'm going to go to the next car
now because I made all the wrong choices
okay I know PS I don't really have kids
animal very lazy and Ivor thank you
thank you much
and I am go line mess with this money
yeah every single time I am a drug
addict but I'm not going to say that out
loud about that one guy on the new turns
off crowd I forget what his dude was
going you happy you said anyways the
when they killed Osama bin Laden all
right everybody I know you with me on
this hatchery USA everything off nothing
super on what I was the loser what L
lose ah just got news well like his
service just you must add like Verizon
some [ __ ] I just picked up in those
[ __ ] underground club oh yeah it's
like bling they kill assemble Isaac
let's go time he's in as soon as I got
everybody and it's past he's all sailors
me USA us it's not one well Orson xx
note so these things up [ __ ] you I can't
believe you just said because you remind
me there was a game pride march in New
York there was they they call to Dyke
parade so it's all gay women
advertisement for that yeah like called
the Dyke parade and when they have it
yeah and Jimmy my buddy Jimmy went down
in March because he apparently is
straight but pertinent I guess I've
known him for 25 20 20 and West Chatham
with all seriousness we had lunch we
hung out is great and what was chilling
watch Adam and he goes he looks at me I
love him Yeah right in love is there
anything that's a little bit that guy so
thank you for that so we saw a couple
plays he and I theater so he owes you
and yep and and Wes looked at me all
dead serious and he goes Jimmy sucks
[ __ ] right oh my god that dead serious
right guys I'm so aggressive and I got
high go this is a southern boy enjoy
southern boy from Georgia there's no
there's no subtle kind of he knows it
are a Jimmy Jimmy sucks a [ __ ] yes oh
yeah I said react and then I don't know
who doesn't he's okay as you and I are
and he goes you serious for real so then
I'm like yeah so we put that to bed and
I'm not kidding the next day he looks at
me again and over lunch and after we saw
another play and he goes Jimmy really
never saw three cops dead serious
so I'm on the subway and it's Gay Pride
and this this gentleman in a rainbow
colored tank top who is probably 60
pounds 70 pounds 80 pounds overweight
just in the face and you know it's like
you're wearing a very skinny tank top
sir but your body couldn't look more
like warm cheese hanging up Oh
tits man tits two big old angry nipples
one of which was pierced and I could see
him peekaboo in right outside that you
know when guys wear tank tops that are
super Bodhi that that glow my Cameron
Hanes I'm talking about the cavern hey
Doc talk about the can hey you know I
love you kill me no a rhythm weird as to
him hey I think I stopped with him since
we enrolled in Colima as well he should
yeah I did just favor man he's a great
be hunting those wild animals and they
he's a great man
but you've got to make funny now did I
get down there and kind of same thing
kind of like kind of crowded and he goes
pride happy pride queer pride no brittle
metal no because nothing it was all gone
I was like wolf I look down there okay
yeah tiny little flag and he went like
this we gotta have some sort of rhythm
you want you everyone involved
I didn't work out about some in New York
man
I bought some pomade in New York like
this apologize expense apologize leave
for everywhere yeah I did go in my room
- oh my gosh thank God I found it open
up someone put their two [ __ ] digits
and just great like two fat God bosses
being yourself sound of like the reals I
got fire it is and it was but I'd say
75% of bottles gone just two fingers OH
oh my god damn it man this is big ol
figure now yeah just two big beaters
just [ __ ] oh I'm done I made steve-o
you could you see the fingerprints we
fell one the prosecutor I could get the
prints I watched you guys steal the
sandwich at the airport i watch the guys
just go
you'll write on them mad and rat on him
he just walked in he goes F F [ __ ] it
maybe have a rubber angular dude man
like in a suit or when I was
what you guys care you might be able to
rock out oh I know that's what it seemed
like okay I'm not gonna bust you for
skillet a $7 sandwich that day that's
the airport for I agree Turkey and
mustard at [ __ ] huh you're fun than one
I had a great time how's your friend
doing Frank he's good tell people what's
going on Frank that's right explain with
it Frank Frank Franco's so he gets run
to you yeah well 25 years and he was
always in our group you know we always
had thousands miles crew and yeah the
part of the new recruit the best played
d1 ball at Hofstra yeah or Fordham
Hofstra one of the other and ran
basketball camps and you know was great
and a good writer did too documentary
films one couple one it went down in New
Orleans after the hurricane and did this
amazing documentary called walking on
dead fish about I think Carrie Bradshaw
it narrated it and was one of the
producers who's really really great
Hurricane Katrina about his kids who
against all odds basically came up with
our own football and saved the football
season it's really really awesome did
another thing about the first one arm d1
basketball player that's going to be
coming all yeah yeah yeah yeah so he's
having an amazing time whatever my
birthday fit did woo you know I'm going
out and wanted a seizure kicking it this
is all from him seizure they're like how
what the [ __ ] it's dog where the parties
are happening well on the highway that's
a good time he's an athlete he's a big
athlete because I can't find six foot
six because he couldn't he goes I
couldn't move my my left hand my left
side was paralyzed he couldn't get the
[ __ ] seatbelt off his dog is there
long story short he finds a way to dial
911 they come ambulance they gotta take
his dog to the pound he's like a
princess what am I afraid shock so you
know when you hear a guy like this talk
and he's a man's man he goes dude they
they go we're gonna give you a casket
who doesn't look so good now we're gonna
give you an MRI doesn't look good at all
looks like you got a brain tumor and
then she opens them up and says well
looks like you are you have the worst
kind of glioblastoma which is a which is
a brain tumor that really sucks so a
large part of the problem with brain
tumors they can't get apparently the
chemo to they will put you on chemo I
think to stop it from spreading
the spider so they can't get the chemo
to break the blood-brain barrier
long story short here's the problem of
brain tumors especially something that
he has and his doctor told him is dr.
goose is doctor goes I want you to think
of a forest your brains our forests now
there's a giant [ __ ] tree now I cut
the tree down but the problem is if
you've ever been to a forest when you
cut a huge oak tree down as they got
roots and those roots are all through
your brain so that's the problem so when
you for the force analogy doctor exactly
exactly so you know until we figure out
a way to get those roots out it's one
thing to operate and get it out but it's
another thing to do everywhere yeah they
left a big web out yeah
but having said all this guys first of
all thank you everybody everybody for
your amazing support people right in the
some great stuff even and so I posted a
video and hence of Gracie gave me this
incredible beautiful like you know post
and you know the one thing about the
good the quick read Frank this is Frank
Frank we had him laughing the whole
[ __ ] time Frank goes look man I got
the worst one like he this guy's on
steroids I got the [ __ ] tumor that's
like let's go you know and the problems
when you cut him they come back me they
mutate even stronger and he goes but
because it's such a maniac there are
doctors
apparently lining up to get him into
these these trials trials when um yeah
because when you have a tumor that's
like that you you get into the
experimental stuff and some of that
nothing really lives and extending life
yes yes there's immunotherapy [ __ ] they
cured one guy with the polio vaccine
they do some crazy so he's gonna be in
the show yeah so he's going to be so
that the irony is as bad as it is he
gets to get into if he talked about when
he when he was sitting in the doctor's
office and the doctor walked ins like
here's what you have yeah and yeah he
did and he said how heavy was well he
said he he goes he goes we had such good
talks about this because he goes they
come in and they basically go listen
we're really sorry you know this is what
we're gonna do but you know you're in
trouble right yeah then you do your
research and you you the Internet's like
you got 11 to 14 months I can't read
Internet you can't read the internet but
what the doctors huddle home the doctors
died of it recently so he he no it is
did you ask him if you would if there
was caught it earlier would have been
yeah no there's nothing in do no the
last time as something that you know
again I think it begins in the brain and
then it roots and then it's already got
these no early signs a you know you
headaches who knows it's one of those
things look we all are going to die
right we're all gonna you know I my hope
is that these trials work for him and
we're talking about talking about in
five years from now but you know Frank
it here's what I love about this dude
this is what's great about Frank he's
not self pitying at all he's like when
we did this benefit from egos a dude I
want to raise money for the disease not
for me I don't give a [ __ ] about me I
want this thing is I want this to not
affect this is affecting kids and stuff
and that's how Frank is he's a man like
he's a he's putting himself the bummer
is in ten years with technology and
stuff to probably have something to get
really of course there are I mean that's
up to cancer research is moving born you
know childhood cancers they're making
huge progress
apparently so you know look we're off
you know spree shooter comes in you get
bitten by shark you get a brain tumor
this is this is what we're all going I'm
not I'm not probably not you're probably
looking at you like a cockroach gonna
live forever unless you move to New York
because just that week Asian be about
live yours look older yeah came back
with acne yeah braces are gone your
hairs all [ __ ] up
your face is all right I need some time
in LA and he thinks more than more ocean
yeah my mother my sister looks at me
because your head looks like a raisin
what's going on I was like I mean she
goes you got to drink a lot of water
right now just dip your head in a bucket
hold your head under Oh in about us so
to until you just to soak your [ __ ]
that raisin head Oaks okay soak that old
raisin head of yours who else did you
see out there
I saw you Jamie a nice driver but I all
my boys look man Jimmy Burke was doing
ballet on his bicycle while me Frank
Jerry you know gazan all of us all Gavin
O'Connor directed the accountant is up
he's he's also in that group all of us
are just around laughing our ass off at
Jimmy just like ol time so talk to I saw
Tariq I thought hung with Tariq and mr.
Jake Shields I love Jake Jake mess in
New York Jake Izzy hey by the way
who reads a lot and can talk to you
about politics and philosophy smart Jake
Shelia smartest [ __ ] I had a great time
at Jake did Jake say he's doing still
yeah he's doing verse various things in
LA I mean I'm sorry in New York and
there's other sins in a tubful different
Bowl yeah so his business lies yeah he's
gonna be jealous about it
yeah I'll be just fine thinking about he
was thinking about do i we did this
Instagram videos I got you sing about
doing instructional stuff on on the web
you know kind of like talking his place
weekend yeah I know that do it let's see
I posted it people eyes do it so we had
a good time man really saying you're
saying he wanted to prove from Instagram
stuff yeah yeah he look at the thing you
do you post on Instagram and that's we
have all yeah they're all good and the
last thing I said to her I go bro when
you from the keep your elbows and body
posture good posture posture posture he
does all those high-level grappling
things one of you should continue that
he's made good money
he's [ __ ] impossible to beat he just
went against doing dannis he and he and
Tariq were telling me that when when
they when they fought tyron woodley like
when when Jake fought tyron woodley
ladies'll yeah and and tyrant you also
be Demian Maia you look at like Jake
Shields pedigree is crazy but he said
when when nobody blows up bigger before
and after way and they said Tarkin Jake
when they well yeah when he saw would be
weighing in literally Tarkin Jake like
look at him he's [ __ ] little you're
going to destroy him and then literally
when Jake saw him getting a cage that
Jake owes literally goes holy [ __ ] and
tacos holy [ __ ] days that 1x1
the quarter wasn't even there to help
him they were like oh [ __ ] he's [ __ ]
huge who added water to that guy
somebody just added water it's like well
dehydration pills like a sponge Phillips
yes yeah so um inside scoop on fighting
guys inside scoop I like your shoes I
want to make fun of them but I can't
because I like how the shore white they
are man yeah they're so comfy you throw
on no socks now you have small socks and
yeah show sucks
you were the business socks which I yeah
I've told you so many times from I give
up I give up what do I wear we should
fight you on this let's
oh yeah I got empowered you get this
guitars Jam I like I like this I like
this cuz I like the color and I like how
the white kind of really pretty to watch
the patio homesite I did you watch it in
New York
yeah no no no I'm sorry I watched it
last night
Holly was I last minute what do you
think so so here's my let me give you my
buddy my my I don't think anybody's
fought back here that way except for
marques in terms of his confidence his
ability to keep that pressure um I do
think it was a robbery but I I just was
so impressed with this kid getting the
gotten that ring to win he got in the
ring every time after that like round he
was like kiyah
he kind of be like good job it was like
kinda like I'm standing right here with
you he can't give up you can't give so
invasive the fact that I went into a
professional boxing match to win so
weird where people say this well but he
had he was 17 I think in one touch them
- no 17 - no I just like this confidence
and I liked I like that he caught many
and with shots first of all a lot of the
stuff was was you know sort of catching
Manny's gloves and arms and the crowd
was going crazy but that uppercut arm
when he caught when he caught him a
couple times went that overhand right as
many as does I mean there was a lot of
stuff where I hadn't seen many actually
get caught clean like that but do I
think that he did enough to win that
fight absolutely not I'd give him maybe
four rounds at the most would you even
give him that many I thought was a
closer fight than everyone thing okay I
also I didn't think it was a robbery at
all like I thought Manny edged it out
here legally
I thought Manny barely etches out those
first like four or five rounds
I mean Horan was doing work and then the
last two you give the horn and then one
as well in the night they're going to
stop here give him about what they did
around job god did you just sick
depending there I can't wanna give that
knock around a 10-8 you know yeah so
it's tough man but listen to the
commentating anywhere off him you listen
to the fight or Timothy Bradley and what
do you think he was this is way closer
and you guys are calling right now I'm
real here's I'm here because you K side
yeah you're ringside I think fighters
who watched it I was like yo he's trying
to bring it to Manny and the other thing
is is
you can't always go off copy strike in
the amount of punches his kind of strike
Adams I think I think maybe I looked in
every round literal akame strike
actually had him hitting him twice as
many times yeah but I don't think you
can we can just go look at time striker
oh there's the winner right cuz you're
talking about horn who's a bigger guy
his cardio is amazed I'm believing for
12 rounds especially like the ninth
round it looked like he was getting I
know he's the big guy he's the aggressor
he'll in a ton of shots
I thought his shots when they landed
really counted more than Manny's yeah so
I didn't think it was a robbery at all
like the ones tweeting out Oh Manny [ __ ]
him I thought Manny got way more screwed
over when he fought Timothy bad oh my
god oh my god Robert that was crazy I
was like what's it happening like damn I
can kind of see it I was like oh my god
boxing years old this is crazy
yeah like I kind of get it yeah yeah
well he also met Manny you know he
didn't look great 38 yeah he looked at
you know he doesn't have the same
knockout power candy find a bigger guy I
thought Horne did a great job this
pressure stuff like that that's
interesting so you think majority of
fighters were not as outraged by that to
say you don't see a lot of five and
scene you know in the boxing penny
people I don't see too many hard many
more the older again boxing had to keep
[ __ ] on Conner and Mayweather you
see these older boxing heads kind of
this is ridiculous this what's wrong
with boxing and then listen the if you
want to say the decision was a travesty
the decision was currency the production
is what everyone should be looking at
that production was also had the camera
shaken Ron Cameron Timothy Bradley
something in Argentina and they said
yeah he goes well with these judges when
we're in Argentina and then it's coaches
roster or how about he goes and then my
Japanese would he say that the co-main
event I [ __ ] even pull myself remember
this to bring it up to you is hilarious
he goes yeah one thing when you fight
these ah [ __ ] it was some word he
definitely shouldn't use for Japanese or
any jobs if you think news did he it was
damn near [ __ ] it was so close he was
thing man oriental when you're in there
when you're in there with the [ __ ] when
you're in there with Japanese I forget
what it was I might have been jabs they
were he didn't say Japs I really is just
the wrong context I was like oh god that
was bad it was bad but the production
was was the issue to me like after the
event there's then there's phone's going
off and they're trying to figure out and
then you have Stephen a Smith yeah
trying to hide - right yeah this is my
problem with Stephen Smith he's
brilliant I get why he's on ESPN because
he's the face of ESPN
I think he's won the best eye ounce in
the game as far as basketball and his
views on that and you can create
headlines but when he goes oh football's
not really a thing basketballs really
really he's monster yeah but yeah he's
got a football and he knows some boxing
but when they went through horns record
and he goes I can read these names who's
he fight and go through names and making
fun of the fighter you don't have that
right man right you have not earned that
right he's only the sport he was I can't
even I can't read the names he fought no
one he has no business being in there
this is going to be a murder this this
isn't going to be a fight this is
hilarious he has no business fighting
guys like dude don't first of all don't
do miss your product you're easier to
hype this fight man second of all it's
coming just so makes part of the guy
because let's go let's we'll get many
patches for 17 fights
can you name those guys now that's
boxing yeah so if you don't know what
you're he made his name horn made his
name on this fight and whoever set this
fight I thought hello laughs and yet you
need that one guys out fight we're all
talking about look look at all the
looking we made with this first 15 17
fights that's the way boxing works
yeah they don't really take me hard
fight for a while so for him to go
through the list of each guy imagine
that guy away from the show like [ __ ]
man hard and he's just Domitian and
making fun of them and oh he's 20
unboxing he's 28 is a math teacher
this guy's hammer shot I'm like bro what
are you doing man yeah and by the way
that's exactly right and then that's why
he's hiding and that's why he's so upset
when they went back to this this is this
is Boston you don't see this in the
youth here with Dana White doing this
[ __ ] like you don't know our sport
at all we have horrible decisions
non-stop boxing so we're having so much
older than it was so weird that he was
gone and saying that you don't see this
in the UFC like you know you'd allow
that Dana White doesn't have any
a on don't know that's the that's the
mission at the Commission the boxing
commission so when I was like Dana White
will that's nothing Commission you know
what it's always furious its pristine
Commission you fool chance I mean she in
fact would that the chance if I window
that I mean we Dan was like they went
off my Maserati with your till the
control back in that freak and I has no
control of it no it's no control you
know I'm not with Boston you can say you
can pay the judge stuff like that I'm
sure there's dark tentacles in that
world but always happened but yeah but
that's what anything right yeah but with
Stephen H Smith and I like Stephen since
I like when he does the box and I like
when he did I think he didn't want 4-h
we got for you what it was and I like
that Eastern has you know they have
lomachenko coming up there proffered him
up I like that it's free it's brilliant
man but that would seem a Smith's like
do don't make fun of the the guy could
be something though and this was his big
shot you know and it goes back to me
he's just roasting everything like ah
[ __ ] man yeah yeah I think it was great
with Teddy Atlas Teddy and the reason
why I like Teddy Atlas is because you
see how he's he's so past fired he's so
passionate and fired up at it it's not
scripted uh and so I think a lot of guys
he is lot of guys I've learned from that
because he's not reading stats and going
off this he put his heart on the line
which I lack know what he's and I
completely disagree with him but I'm
open am i enough to list them and change
my opinion like if I was there with him
I'd be open-minded enough like why do
you think that right but most guys
aren't they're stuck in their ways and
then Teddy Atlas was just going off and
then how about when Teddy else was in
interviewing them and goes you know
you're pretty stand-up guy but do you
really think you won that fight because
I don't think you did a gut takes balls
do man he's right from in anyway he
think you won that but earned that I
appreciate me too now she dismisses that
yeah no man you did not ready Atlas has
it has the know he's a hall-of-famer
yeah
Boston hold favor and he's Bradley's
coach right that's right and when
Bradley [ __ ] here this was close
fight man I don't know you know Pat you
had his hands full and tell you let's
discuss some because you're telling me
in your heart of hearts you really think
torn won that fight be dead Allah said
and you know cuz Bradley kind of hating
on pack out the whole thing right they
have their whole issues and he goes now
I think Manny
have some ladies like there you go
hilarious man oh that's a that's
brilliant yeah he's great that kind of
honesty that will because Teddy Atlas is
reacting to what he's seeing
yeah like directly and based on his also
his years of being in the ring and yeah
I mean that's that's who you really
listen to that's who you put the most
stock into you have to actually I would
like I would I wonder how that works as
max elements HBO boxing but he works for
ESPN
I want refusing me donated Aloma chenko
and Crawford fights because when will
che going to be on HBO now he's with
ESPN right if he's fighting on there is
I wonder if Max Kellerman can do
anything for ESPN during those fights
because Max and seem a Smith could be
good because I don't think max is in let
see me Smith get away with that stuff
well max I'm accessories asking a world
well didn't Steven before he roasts the
guy for his record of being 70 no listen
in Boston look at these linens of guys
this how it usually goes and go oh I get
it
action oohs do you have no one there to
check them he knows his stuff all you do
is have a ESPN the host there who also
doesn't know the game he's also a boxing
purist I was very interested to hear him
max is my favorite yeah but but he was
variant seeing here Andre Ward who said
about the Pacquiao because I'm sorry
that Mayweather foot from McGregor fight
you know he kind of said what you've
said come with me which was paid to it's
gonna be hey goes you know I think that
Manny I mean that that Floyd's gonna
feet got to feel him out for three four
rounds you know and then he's going to
go to work then you're gonna see the guy
go to work he's gotta figure his buddy
and Max kind of went uh three or four
rounds
I'll give him about a minute and a half
then he's going to start talking to us
about what he's going to do and I think
a minute has not enough time to download
everything might be might be but I with
Andre Ward says that then I go okay
because Andre Ward's videos 200 well how
would know with MMA guy yeah with Nate
Diaz Nick Diaz he's been in hell oh my
gosh yeah ton of those guys yeah but the
thing with Max oh man and I get it man
I'm same way with him I made but he's so
narrow-minded when it comes to boxing
it's actually hurting him on this fight
when he comes to Conor and Floyd he just
can't be open my enough to think that
Conor can bring some sort of danger the
table yeah I actually think it's hurting
his
Allyson but is there any way that
someone like who's big like Connor and
watches that horn Pacquiao fight is
there anything in that where where
Connor would say I'm gonna [ __ ] crime
in a crowd
the way he crowded Manny's where he gave
Manning no breathing room no they can't
do that cuz yeah because that's kind of
color style so for for Connor we
encounter Washington County yeah but for
Connor it's a he has to do what down to
the party would make some kind of
Gregory which is using his distance yeah
not I mean he's not a brawler yeah so we
heard hear people say that psych Jim
well know what Connor did this dance and
this the biggest fight of all time the
biggest sport event of our lifetime is
his left hand
gauging distance using his angles so for
so for people to say oh well look
Maidana gave me with a bronze or horn
gave Manny Proms he just needed to scout
out why would why would you sell out
everything that makes you special and
adapt to something Floyd is seen before
I like to Connor said to Dana
I want khabib in Russia oh you bought
that ok shout out hand
thank you let's see I always wonder if
people buy that and I roast I roasted
people for most people linings yy-you
know what you're a course Connor didn't
say that looks Dana protecting his ass
Oh Danny of course I think no puts
pressure on Connor so he has to fight
for the LCM I Eli he missed and what we
miss quoted you don't you think he just
said that if he just comply really he
completing it
Oh what Dana lied to the public I see I
thank put your application hang whatever
Tina's crazy is people still buy it yeah
but I can still gain traction to me but
like so many times oh yeah but over and
over they rolled over a that country's
never gonna fight again just be scared
to fight again oh I'd say major hey
what's wrong I would just be arches I
medical Dana knows you see knows okay I
can't I can't believe people still buy I
don't know but I got read that some lame
I know I buy a baby let's just go over
there in what world if your car McGregor
coming up nine figure payday to Floyd
Mayweather
right why would you fight could even
Russia and let's just look it could be
social media falling they name the last
time to be was a main event and
headlined a card off because such a drum
yeah well he's a superstar in Russia but
that's it ah
I guess we go he's huge in Europe that
doesn't sell paper if it doesn't that
doesn't work no here's one just give me
a few reasons if you're Conor McGregor
it adds up as a manager why you let him
fight could be even Russia well that
does know that's actually not the that's
I think for Conor to fight khabib walks
around at 200 pounds me I'll take all
that out or it isn't just go for reason
I think it was I think it would be a
very bad businesses and personally but
here's what I'm saying when Dana White
says that Conor said that like that's
where if he's actually saying that Conor
said something he didn't say if I was
Conor I'd be pissed about that coming so
but listening cause I'm in a dress so
you think dana says so Dana will
actually say what other fighters said
like make up what they said I I think it
could have been taken out of context I
think it could have been discussion
where hey man if you get to this fight
you still fight for the UFC and so they
brought in Congress coach because I
Connor said I probably won't fight at
the end of December whoo man what about
Russia what about what about could be a
cousin a lot of - what about what about
me and he's like I'll fight I don't give
a [ __ ] I'll play a game act now that's
kind of the fighter saying there now she
gets to Boyd Mayweather and you run that
this table of [ __ ] brilliant minds
ago here's our option let's just look at
our options
so in this why things happen the Conor
McGregor fight he's going to win the
spectacle he's going to lose in decision
but he's gonna win the spectacle meaning
he's going to win round you're all
hearing me talking about after his fight
is Conor McGregor he's in lane some
shots are gonna get replayed over and
over but he's gonna lose the fight yeah
we didn't win the spectacle which at
which ends up Connor winning in the long
run so then you're sitting down at the
table right here's your options the
killer could be even Russia all right
now we know he's not a draw and we don't
even know if he can make 55 remember
he's mr. 55 a few times now his livery
gave Adam so let's go on a world wide
[ __ ] marketing tour but we're not
positive and make the way so there's
that option okay all right now and I'll
here's my monster in net yeah an easel
probably the worst matchup we can think
up for now could you beat him maybe you
could Chancellor I tell ya here's the
second one we had 20 Ferguson
now here's $30,000 okay and he's not a
big draw
inskipp tough matchup here monster now
we need you to
that card as well yeah or here's the
third option oh it's great D is that
survived the trilogy and you're gonna
make so much Bank and it's actually you
beat them before these be before this
one makes complete sense it'd be the
biggest UFC papery of all time now if
you wanted to hold Russia you want fight
Tony would you like name let's just put
a hands in the air oh wow it's unanimous
Nate Diaz in a trilogy what name is so
weird to be suing it's when I see Danny
say stuff that ain't happening that
ain't happening
good to know my word why would you go
from Floyd everybody can be even Russia
yeah well the only reason I bought into
it then that that know that Conner is
the kind of fighter that would challenge
himself with them which he well yeah but
you have a team behind that guns also to
this point Connor is a guy that go I
will fight anyone any given day any time
any way pattern he's the one when Nadine
about 70 they go let's run back 55
because nope I can do it at 70 yeah and
he did it right so he's that type of
dude but a fighter has a team around the
world chill gym just like before you
want to fight Nate again right away at
55 no no there might be this boy they
were like yeah your uh dragons you're
not ready for Frankie Edgar yet let's
fight Cub Swanson
but the fighting marks the fighter
always wants to fight yeah fighters that
are always a true fighter wants that
that fight but here's a team random rule
could be even Russia yeah Thank You
Jessie shoes in Russia in the states it
could be walked in this office right now
with tiramisu not one person would stop
them not one person he could walk in
there with his Russian hat on not one
personal asking for an autograph yeah
Conor Watson here's the emergency
[ __ ] alarm goes off shut this place
down yeah you're talking about a
pop-culture
crossover each time up the biggest name
in sports right now yeah against this
Russian he's big in Russia though that's
the pitch yeah he's big in Russia yeah
and Dagestan and Chechnya you know the
pay-per-view numbers that designer of
I'm not mean Ukraine I'm just saying
that there's an area like look at
Klitschko ones great save awaits multi
yeah looks like what's down the street
obviously ever person stock on it goes
at him
you got boxing burn but he's just a
Boston where there no one person stopped
with yeah wow I'm like this Klitschko
McMahon no matter matter
doesn't matter huge in Europe doesn't
matter doesn't work like that yeah I
think we'll see the Nate and I'm happy
for an ideas because he'll cash in on
that make some real money
hopefully him ah brother just got spin
it and then yeah and I think it's funny
if you were like free free MIT and Nick
Diaz Fremont man it's he made the
mistake yeah
do you know how you soliders they do
random testing you have to tell me
location and he didn't ever gave him his
location so if you missed three test you
that means you failed the test
Wow and he just never gave him his
location so then you failed the test
yeah it was like this is that this is
ridiculous free Nick Diaz like no Delsea
he's done fighting you don't give a [ __ ]
free from want man you made your bed be
late like you know the rule joining the
THC right into his body and you know and
hanging out speaking she didn't see
Derek Louis's statement he was out with
don't you be tired
he is bad I just want some time off I
want to smoke a little weed so it test
me non-stop
I just want to smoke a little weed iou's
I got kids they get my goddamn nerves I
wanna smoke some weed great he's funny
he's hilarious yeah he's got how glad
he's not retiring right everybody
division needs him oh yeah they need
them bad
what is the guidance like where did you
may have talked about this but where
does we haven't talked about it worried
enough kana very happy she's very happy
about Matt Mitrione and knocking out
fives on balls even where does he go by
there he's late where's he go just I
mean I told madam on my show last week
he needs to demand a vacant heavyweight
title now that's what he has to do right
is there's no heavyweight title holder
it's just vacant I don't know why Matt
and it the balls in his corner so he
just needs to demand that fight a guy
maybe uh I Chuck Congo LaBrie match or
if boy wins I worry what I saw mister
Congo at the Bellator fights and easy a
well-dressed handsome you saw her you
man yeah used to are only fashion brands
African yeah the first AP yeah
yeah French African yeah you so I want a
clothing store and we ho what a good
imagine what a [ __ ] yeah I can do and
trust about [ __ ] that's nice as we
come to ah is he I don't know that's
nice it up now is like on these flights
are like watching
can two sloths grapple yet it is like it
is but he's undefeated
he's I'm so far in his last I think
seven he's one Monroe but they're just
it is tough
took his like watching to just just
tired lizards just kind of kind of
figure it out really it's so boring
but listen he's one you know he's doing
his job he's a vet he's not taking shots
anymore so I could see him and Matt for
the vacant title and he avoiding else he
got bobby lashley they're like there's a
lot of good matchups for Matt but
formats time to get going yeah yeah I
saw mr. Rory MacDonald walked by me very
impressive
you left the fights early huh yes throw
into the boat here yeah I did you call
yourself a fight ban yet you walk out on
a fade or main of them so hungry that I
was gonna die yeah their food there
though I didn't care I was so hungry I
was with Jimmy and Jimmy was bored Jimmy
was like he doesn't know he's like
you're like all right yeah just doesn't
know I haven't keeping him there and I
was like alright because can we just he
was starving I god let's get out of here
I'll watch it on [ __ ] you know hey
well we talked about you private on top
of Aaron peak on stuff ah dude yeah
can't miss when he came jump that little
and thanks for covering them it was fun
to have Tony Hinchcliffe he was making
me laugh so [ __ ] hard III bet one of
our most downloaded episode he was so
really funny man dude he was killing it
you know we had Aubree on his good to
see Aubree here yeah really you see of
it I wish you here with Aubree was
interesting stuff yeah my stupid [ __ ]
bovine he's Moglen did he cuz he's
really been focusing on his podcast and
his new one and he has people on he said
Jamie Foxx on you know Boyd Piven on
he's having more more people on is he's
so much better on the mic another he
wasn't bad before but before it was like
you know just saw what the thing you
know what he just was not comfortable
but now you know he can talk so much
more like he's a BS but he's getting
really really good yeah the more you do
so practice yeah but Tony man he's
pretending because you heard the Chinese
lady that through change in the jet
engine for good know she was going to go
on plane and she's like huh well good
luck you know I lost the [ __ ] changes
of the engine and it sucked engine up
and they couldn't take off like sick
hours Tony's pretend to be the Chinese
lady dude it's all my favorite [ __ ]
segments on this show really I was
laughing so hard and then I told them
that I your aunt Elizabeth said I don't
like almost crying County Center like
well if it was 2009 yeah I get it but
it's kind of central now man that's many
people this looks so funny but it
retains the Chinese lady that's crying
oh my god dude
but I knew Alya crowd Japanese accent to
which made it funnier it is so because
the Chinese system or you know you more
like a bit a bit more like rounding the
verbs because that's you know for
Cantonese or Mandarin it's a more like
that too but I yeah that is a Japanese
Japanese it's more a little ooh whole
whole er it was y'all you can be sure
about all right look how would I you
know cover that you will die no very
very difficult boy do you want a very
difficult by I'm standing a little bit
like am it's a very macho though very
macho language because I turned the meri
Pacquiao fight I'd looked up there so
antagonist of his wife yeah
Instagram account and it is pure comedy
because you know the Philippines they
come from nothing and then there's a
billboard in the Philippines
it's her she said you know it's just
she's like Kardashian she had faced down
her tits done ass and she's a psyched
and it goes whatever name isn't I forget
a name but what it is
Penelope with a [ __ ] Amos it goes five
kids working mom anything is possible
and it's a billboard of fur in all her
plastic surgery and it's like as a
number for plastic surgery and then
it'll be her in front of like a Fendi
store and complete Gucci and should be
like anything's possible when you pray
with God like well and you have a great
doctor health side you have a great
scientist but but also yeah okay well
yeah and it's just so weird to me man
strange yeah it's funny though I'm gonna
go back and listen that Tony Angela
thing I remember when I was 14 years old
I've never been more insulted in my life
you know Bruce Lee it was not only my
hero
took him seriously because before in the
day I thought all I should fermentor
dragon was 100% real life you think
about that guy's a bad end time and I
was like that this is my this is not
only my hero he's my god and there I've
never forgot I watched a movie at my
boarding school this is 1981 okay and
back when all kinds of prejudices were
basically very verbal and loud you could
be if you were Asian it was it was not
that fun because it was still accepted
Lee it was acceptable immigrant and he
there's a line where he said something
to and Bruce Lee goes he didn't have a
very good accent he goes the line was I
will old man and he goes I will old man
and when he goes I will oh man
so hallways like their hobby and I was
so offended out you don't [ __ ] laugh
at Bruce Lee don't laugh it's not a
strike you [ __ ] I will oh man
and then my friends will go I will I
will oh man oh hey bro seriously one
more time roalvang who will buy wait not
really dead just so you know all right
all right
did you I don't know if it's kind of an
efficient he can stop me but I was
watching this like good more good more
in America today there was this I don't
know I'm laughing
there was this always laughing Caroline
well no this is uh interesting get your
opinions but there's this overweight
she's a plus-size model
I said plus she like plus plus XI plus
plus plus she ain't the missus any meal
you know you say meat and we're really a
plus like she cost hahaha she blonde
plus plus but it might as well be wrong
yeah so she gets the mercy aisle and
she's the middle seat but she sick like
a mound bar yeah she got by like rocky
road I got it you got boxcar Willie
sitting Bhaskar will it would be cool
eyes on that before were you sitting
next I mean they're all cozy they're so
heavy that it's cozy
you're like I mean I will fly off me -
it's like the video woman you just like
that move
zero six you know that the big like
white guy that blows up that robot yeah
hero six I think let's call it's like
sitting next to that I find it
comforting well I said I appreciate that
because if it's a big woman I'll be like
just so you know I'm gonna use you as
McCutchen I'm just so you know press up
against that big arm and that side
notice all of the tricep oh yeah that
big old tricep so saw as well you know
you look like a lazy boy to me lazy boy
I got reclined but I think I've never
loved in and that's how can I go mommy I
just take a fold I just take a fold from
that tricep and just plop it on my
throat on like like I'm a big old shark
a puppy just my mommy you got come on
come on yeah for sure quit sweating them
yeah but anyways so this plus plus size
model get as the middle seat emergency
section G sits down X this guy and this
guy is roasting her to his friends on
his text though he didn't say to her but
he's on his text like holy [ __ ] and his
friend goes hopefully she didn't eat eat
Mexicans you know I'm planning that she
can be farting yeah and he goes no she
looks like she ate a Mexican you know
like but he's having a private
conversation just joking around it's not
for her to see not hurt feelings he's go
back it out l Snoopy Snoopy plus-sized
reads the tera waits for the flight to
lands three-hour flight from I think I
forget and Astrid la or some [ __ ] like
that
three-hour flight wait till the flight
then as a plan she puts on video and
goes excuse me I want you know before we
took off that's like saying some pretty
hurtful things about my size to your
friends the guy goes oh sorry I was
drinking you know you're so C down
because why did see shouldn't talk about
people out where he goes I'm sorry
and then she's like yeah you she did
more if I should be sorry and she's like
I apologize you know I had some drink -
you're right I shouldn't be saying
anything like that and then he sit
mingoes I can actually love it he goes
you know you're the mercy Sachin you
know when they go hey are you capable to
help anyone open the sized doors you
know are you fit enough to that would
you say you're capable enough to do that
he's like like should you really be
sitting in mergency section so on it's
quite a fair question and fair question
a little rube
it's not actually a fair question she
was I'm completely capable of helping
people so it's like are you though if
[ __ ] hit the fan are you really gonna be
the most physically I might be in the
white people yeah we have to Matthews
afloat or something like that dumb thing
you know I'm saying well I have that
poor guy might have been so embarrassed
he was embarrassed but this is my eyes
watch it at first
see I thought did he get a lot of [ __ ]
for it was she she like she didn't show
his face because she goes I don't want
shaming on shaming arts because you
remark good for actually support but the
thing is is here's here's where my issue
with this is is it's a conversation a
private conversation context that she's
not supposed to see yeah if you're if
you're judged based off the way you talk
to your friends do a private
conversation my god
we're all fine yeah I'm Rob [ __ ] but
Podesta comes to scream you know I go
out of my way to say the most offensive
[ __ ] on the planet if I'm talking to you
yeah we're videos where we try to make
each other laugh you trying to raise the
bar yes but that's not for the public
that's not fruits and maybe what you see
and I don't want anybody I would never
want I don't want to hurt anybody's few
guys I think I see if I was I got my job
so I'm just trying to my friends laugh
this is it
you weren't you're not supposed to see
that yeah I like the bigger issues why
are you looking at my goddamn phone
right how about that there is this this
this transgender I don't know this guy
walks in woman but it's a guy and a
giant man who clearly feels like a woman
inside but we did a bad job with
whatever was that trying to look
feminine
at least I could do dwith addresses I
mean it was the craziest thing I've ever
seen and I was like you know wolf that's
that's a tough way that I mean first of
all it's tough to have that bone
structure when you want to be probably a
woman
gaudí but you know my buddy was saying
some funny [ __ ] he's not against he's
not trying to make that person but he
wasn't doing it no no he would never
ever return me bad person see he waited
until she turned her bad hitting Rosalie
if it says we all good it doesn't mean
that we're prejudiced no there were bad
PPS ain't really that like expect more
like I've seen that happen I like yeah
my only my friendly yeah like it just
acknowledged like that's a dude in the
dress or if you see a beautiful woman
who's got like cleavage and she's
walking
which is a blowout us you and I are
gonna say some [ __ ] does it mean not
really any worse I gotta see to do that
you know see I assume as a male if a
dime piece Watson I don't need you going
bra oh I love that I'm always like to
you that maybe I missed out it's like I
have two eyes and a fat dick of course I
see that I get it I don't need you to go
you know what the [ __ ] I would do that
I'd what would you do why don't you tell
her what you would do want to tell
everyone to hear what you would do Doug
David how are you doing this that's
David all used to do a great joke about
that he'd be like I can't be can't stand
being around friends the guy walks in
guy you know the girls there and he goes
the things I would do to that chick I'd
be [ __ ] to her where she could never
look her own mother in the face again oh
my god well I'll tell you what serial
killer we're taking this relationship as
far as the scoggs I don't know what the
[ __ ] time he's high on you're away from
you right now I never do I don't have
those guys were like you know hey bro
but you see that of course I dig it as
an insult when guys think that I missed
that too I'm always like a bro bro over
there Mike there's that 10 that's been
sitting over there to my right for five
minutes
you think I miss that [ __ ] don't how
dare you I saw a guy run away I got
intent I don't need you to point up yeah
I also need you to acknowledge that you
saw it yeah my dick has its own sensor
he spit out his out camera she was a
block away in a scanner yeah so she's
fat athletic goes like you [ __ ] a rat
here's the day I'll do to you sometimes
I'll see a woman walk in and sometimes a
woman is I'll tell you is not afraid of
a plus-size woman today right now me but
that guy she's in my left gotten I don't
know I don't want I'm not medium rare
plus plus well another like not not like
the girl in the moon zero no not you but
you're not afraid of a plus-size model I
mean but I'm not going to point any
fingers but something's on my face bro
I'm just saying some people you'll to
not look at him but I'll look at her I
will walk in and look because there's
some women guys back no way to to them I
like them in I'll just look at Brennan
and I'll go you would tell go hard every
day just like hi I got you pegged
reduces listen I appreciate it you're an
equal-opportunity employer you're not
you're not picky that way well
don't need all the perfect light you you
always take it easy that's about my
dealings gonna blow up with a chicken
just Jenny Craig not brown man it's a
girl a girl if a woman had him know that
I mean even women that's little weight
and a goatee you're not afraid of that
that's what I'm trying to say is you
like the same way I'd like to but if you
don't want to hear them getting blocked
in with him some cauliflower I'll look
at you yo you [ __ ] them and you're like
wow there's nobody protects out men more
than me why was that guy oh we roasted
you for quite some time about when Jesse
walked doing that big guy named big baby
and my baggage brought Jessica it's so
strange he goes he not gain the least of
it
no if I am Nora if it's a big guys
fearing strange man he was a big baby
big baby was this big he made you look
like he did he was talking about that
and J we got pictures he's not that big
only 315 pounds and there's not a lot of
fat on that's a big boy that's a big
fella I was a sailor does not laughs I
like I like him he's a tough dude
ringing mutters he's not talking about
ah you're not skinny no no this imagine
you Adam but his bone structure he said
well if you know Diaz he's probably a
lot like somebody's NFL like line
alignment
he got you tapping yeah just a really
big big frame oh no not much just you
know John you know was it
I think this no no no I slapped that guy
for God's yeah that's all about him I'm
talking about nice but a very nice guy a
nice we had a really good time don't
ever wear a military time again nice is
our sweetheart sweetheart of a guy I'm a
big baby kickboxer there's a lot of big
babies in sports for God's sakes guys I
guess there is huh that's funny cuz I
thought he was the only one for real
Jarell Noah yeah yeah yeah Nick Dan King
Kong a
agar damages bad guy he [ __ ] cro cop
making out just image you know alone
sick yeah he's that person he's not fat
oh I see what you're saying yeah he's a
big big fella that's a large man see
he's not ski not shredded no no he's not
shredded no y'all watch your P's and Q's
everybody know he's Samoan he's got that
Simone we got some although he's blast
wsn Samoan structure but yeah but no
he's not african-american team is fat
no he's just he said yeah very thick
very thick sort of [ __ ] song that's in
tip-top
you know I'm gonna take the pair
I got a test here come on let's go do
this
let's do some current events what do we
got current events
ah um you guys already kind of know
about this I'm sure so Jamie Horowitz is
going to be or he's actually let go from
Fox now yeah and Brendan just went on a
rant about something he said about
Shannon Sharpe not a Maanshan sharp you
know when you say we own Shannon Sharpe
across all platforms that that's a I
understand what that brings up based on
history the question becomes I don't
know what why if that's the reason I
fired but apparently there's it's not
social harassment but is it the sexual
harassment it's a sexual asthma being
tagged on here no why did this come out
of nowhere all of a sudden I understand
uh frying my resources but it's it has
nothing with the Shan sharp stuff this
is that going to be God that could have
been just like I apologies now that
there's anything to apologize to or
anything okay I think everyone at Fox
knew what are you saying I did - I'll
say I'm just reaching here I was
roasting the guy but everyone knows what
was going on there yeah um I think for
Jamie
you know it's sexual harassment it's a
probe when they say probe is Fox and the
guy who let him go censor it when they
let him go this fast
there's give me some [ __ ] coming out man
Fox trying to get on top of it before
this stuff it's non-public the only
worry I have is head so you can get
fired based on accusation right so if
you have if you're in a position of
power and you have you know you work in
an environment now where when you say
nice dress you use chocolate out of
context make a yummy sound whatever it
might be you know those things are that
can just be a guy talking or whatever it
is flirting and somebody misinterprets
out somebody country that either side of
that it's not that no he didn't go you
have a nice dress on or make it sound a
chocolate right I can guarantee you that
but right now it's a probe so you're
saying there's enough evidence you think
that they're trying to get ahead of it
that's well no we mean they already fire
a fire yeah it's not like you're
confident what they believe Wow oh no
and we hired he hired a powerful defense
they can defend it what are you get
nasty yeah what what are you doing in
the workplace what's going on here what
do you think is really interesting I got
to see I mean just didn't seem like the
sky was that great of a guy and the guys
for me I thought you know be everyone
hit me up on Twitter State now like the
guy there I never once even get fired
loser job you know I don't know if he's
a terrible human being I don't know him
that well my interactions with them you
know he's a little cocky and you know
maybe have right to be in this position
stuff like that actually tweet something
out was like you know when he got fired
I went jeez I don't think the
three-on-three basketball idea was that
bad like I don't really joke around I
delete it cuz I'm gonna take the high
road here I don't want anyone get fired
you know yeah I have no idea what's
going on there I have no qualms or any
hatred towards Fox that just like Fox I
gave us one all that stuff but you know
that would be it's not a matter of him
if he's doing his job poor this is such
a harassment I have nothing to do with
that yeah yes especially harassment if
you did come on you don't think I would
have told you guys
yes hilarious yeah so I grabbed my dick
I saw him eating be cooler I encouraged
that I admired live-tweeted yeah I wish
yeah the question is with some
completely it seems like a lot of these
men are being taken down for sexual
harassment and and I'm you know I'm not
a woman I know of cases where it's like
really subtle where you you get asked
out you say no you know and now what do
you do then that the your attentions I
hear you don't on saying I hear
everyone's hunting the white male right
now I get it's tough being a white male
this is different the question is what
do you what is that is cuz arrest more
is this kind of stuff do to change minds
persuade things is punishment and is
this kind of sort of zero-tolerance
policy something that's actually going
to build resentment or change minds does
it make it of those well what's the work
environment now like because I've heard
and read a lot about work environments
where it used to be a place where you
could joke around with each other now
everybody's terrified to joke around
with each other you know and so I just
wonder malleability Foxwoods dill is too
much joking around
not work I mean they were having some
trouble too much fun they're having some
troubles big trouble yeah I think it was
here means you know it'll be interesting
to see what comes out the magnitude of
them firing this fast and the way they
did it I'm telling you it's gonna be
intense
yeah it's what she's guy who fired them
yeah it's just ain't one of those things
where girls pass they don't do this
lightly they got a lot of they got a lot
he was just getting starting at least
you know yeah it's me some [ __ ] comes
out yeah yeah what else you got I'll buy
that all right the next one is the odds
for McGregor and Mayweather apparently
his odds of beating or punching and
knocking out Mayweather are higher than
if Canelo were to knock out triple G
yeah see I think you can get a lot of
this just because it's that whole
x-factor thing that the Vegas oddsmakers
haven't seen and don't know really how
to you know put put the odds on it
because it's something you haven't seen
so it's going to be lower because they
don't know with Canelo in triple G we
know exactly what they bring the table
we know exactly how they're going to
fight you know exactly what style
they're going to bring with Conor we've
never seen them in a boxing ring so they
don't know it's really you know of
course can be lower because again it's
that X fact of the unknown or well does
that and did you follow the chris
Christie thing that's going on now okay
so hilarious so New Jersey government
had to shut down because of a budget
standoff between New Jersey government
and then state lawmakers and so because
of that their state beaches and all our
stuff parks shut down right and then
Chris Christie was caught on one of
those beaches with his family the Beast
has shut down he's sunbathing they're
just kind of hanging out and didn't he
didn't it wasn't his rebuttal didn't he
say well you're not the comforter like
he was Collins like suction up he's
always been a real kind of like crust
guy he doesn't be like that I look go
[ __ ] yourself just the way it goes
that's just the way forever and you can
have a residence that's rough
he's actually a funny guy he's here he
any weight any way he could lose weight
he's always had
problems because it's problems with his
weight yeah it's he's got issues there
that's for sure
what so so so he set it down than him
and his family there it's kind of crazy
oh dude because Jersey right now the
Jersey Shore is Hugh that's what they're
saying they go you shut it down when the
business times of the year is he in the
dimness yeah that's that's crazy so
ultimate power vu yeah so the delayed
stage wants to spend more money and he's
saying no way is that what was that what
these I don't know it's actual the cata
of what they're caught up with in the
budget but they just they're not
agreeing I don't know if he's the one
that wants to spend more hey leave this
look cool from damn a Lyme governor
could you shut up for a second chris
Christie new jersey city tiny shutting
down the beaches is crazy are the
beaches shut down when you can't go
though what no one else is lovely do you
want to see what a disaster that is for
Jersey this is crazy the Jersey Shore is
everything in the same art and look
everybody believed that poor chair just
barely anything hanging out that pier
that chairs have a hard time forget oh
oh oh my Wow
that's crazy you see the picture him
throwing the first pitch Jesus Christ
you see it didn't can I see that just
bring up Chris Chris don't have to see
that baseball no not at nut he's a big
he talk stuff like a big construction
worker over there there's a great field
images oh that you can't wiggle paper
you can't wear your pants that's real
yeah like that oh that's hilarious
though yeah he's very funny he could
give a [ __ ] but damn it those are tight
pants er yeah they're so tight yeah
there's a very tight pants little doing
work Oh like [ __ ] Babe Ruth's back
yes oh man that's at there's a lot of
that bat looks like your goddamn wiffle
it sure does it looks like a looks like
a stick it's like we playing stickball
it's so hilarious he shipped on the
beaches and shows up with his family
ah I give him up he's down you don't
like a lot of people
governor what else you got you how about
this one this Brazilian drug lord he's
been on the run for 30 years and he
finally got caught he actually did
plastic surgery to his face and was able
to escape the authorities for 30 years
holy [ __ ] Wow that's how it was before
and
well the plasters really didn't let's
say that it better kept changing it
that's that's one of the reasons
weddings right they're really not that
far of a stretch that screw out a goatee
yeah as you can
30 years though we can much money is
worth 100 million Wow damn that's fun
where did they catch him at I think it
was a sandwich shop ah ain't fellas
jewelry shop never my oh there is damn
ah got caught [ __ ]
that's it's weird too I'm always a
little bummed when they catch a do
design no I think it's the whole uh
narcos thing yeah damn that for sure get
other sound gain an outlaw like that for
that long getting away with it there are
terrible people though they kill so many
piece sure do yes all family they'll
chocolate shirts on a disability more
debate really yeah like all the kids the
mom the dad Lee Kent
damn it hello sketch in at America um so
this dude a stranger in New Jersey
somehow snuck into a woman's house
climbed in her bed and asked if he could
spend the night with her well no then
that's the that's the illustration and
this is the actual dude Wow the Korean
guy ah look at the illustration you're
like those I don't seems so different
God did it because not even cry as his
hair push to the side yeah you know
hyung see the real yeah that's what go
done wait so he just dumped in bells
like he's anyway I could just take it
probably kind of his pride creo was he
trying to uh sexual assault or even he's
just trying to get a few winks in we
didn't a soldier but I mean obviously
that is all about winks in but he's been
he's been stalking women before uh yeah
we're gonna go and lock him up gotta go
ahead and lock yep you can't crawl on
somebody's bed at night that's like this
woman who this guy crawls him to a
woman's bed rapes her and you know kind
of saying stuff like you're my
girlfriend and tapes her mouth shut then
he's been he robbed her and the woman
remembered what he looked like and then
got of somebody to draw it up and put
his fly
airs all over her neighborhood that this
guy came in red guess who turned him in
whose mom well mom as I love my son but
he's a [ __ ] scumbag
you know Wow so the illustration
actually looked like her son then yeah
oh yeah this hokum contra lowered its
way glasses on god that's terrifying
they should fire that horrible woman
it's terrifying for a man if that little
guy got into my bed and I can I spend my
clothes
yeah that guy I get out quick yeah done
here I go terrified clammy hand would
you grab Hold'em and and choke him or
would you jump out of bed real quick you
I play kick him as hard as I could like
a mule kick if you come out with that
yeah yeah good
I'd be so bored he got up on onions I
got like a big I'll be so scared man and
scary especially when you wake up in the
middle of night son James owned that one
time I don't know if I should tell story
but I will one time in Venice when I was
I was going through a long break up with
my you know you get one of the breakups
where you still talking should happen
two years ago coming over and yeah it's
a breakup though she moved out you guys
are not on good terms but there's still
weird love there there's still [ __ ] up
miss and old Bry was moving on you had
to stand he was moving on and I had this
other girl who is just amazing and we we
had a night full of rough and and
passionate lovemaking and we all sleepy
sleeping and in the middle of the night
I hear my window somebody's trying to
break into my window and they kept the
window open Christian guy and I'm like I
wake up in the middle and I start to
screams I think somebody's coming in I
go ah ah and I'm trying to fight a gun
I'm trying to look for my gun cleaning
looking for a deal and trying to look
for my guns I go you got a reaction it's
my son break-in and I hear you [ __ ]
scumbag I knew it I knew it and I'm like
and now I'm like it's my girlfriend I'm
like aah and now screaming like the
screaming changes from combat to skin it
was a war crime ah like that now I'm
going
ah and all I can do is scream at the
[ __ ] window and she just she didn't
come in she goes
[ __ ] you and leaves I run out trying to
what I was going to say we were already
broken up but he's back here with me and
you know what my girl said it was in my
bed she goes you have a really good
heart listen I did you felt bad for her
I appreciate that I go yeah I did I was
terrified
Jesus Christ he has a lot that whether
she had sinned
check this out there's this dolphin that
approach this boat and I guess there's a
guy's a fisherman and he just wanted to
get his belly rubbed
how cool like that is so cool
I'm kind of tell like this is a
legitimate dolphin actually wanting to
get human contact that's amazing and
then it he turns around more than having
the looks like in a cut as b-cup do
dolphins ever attack humans no no no
often just so smart it wickets look at
that mess in Ireland really do you know
what is clear in ireland sure is that's
amazing - I jump in there we would swim
away together to help grab onto this I
would grab his fin like okay this
dolphins is typically short round right
now I don't think now typically they're
not they avoid each other yeah dolphin
would protect me I go take me to
Atlantis and he would take me to it yeah
I'd love to ride on them as well until
you so to ditch you in the middle of a
[ __ ] ocean Steve Byrne has a joke
where he because um you're never there's
nothing you're never more gay than when
you're riding a dolphin with your hands
on the grass Joker [ __ ] it because
that's when you're the gay when you're
riding a dolphin in yours and you open
your hands see dude look and what is the
dying as possible is yeah it's so true
the red one but uh nor do I collect it
by the way - I've won I know by the way
so many animated living animated my
massage story
at about Bora Bora and I said I think I
gave I believe I gave al Madrigal credit
for but his joke of did is that your
banana you're going to make your banana
cry and you know that's an out that's an
old al magical joke and but I think I
gave him credit afterwards but they
didn't put in there so I can't post it
because it's Alec killed but I like text
now I'm like dude I'm really sorry it
sounds like I stole your look yeah I
mean you know I'm telling a story and I
use that little as an old joke they did
a long time ago but you have to like it
but I think I hope I get credit after do
I do
joke soon yeah I'm joke stealing what
else yet you there's another animal when
a moose chased this dude on a golf
course I don't know how a golf moose can
get on a golf course but this is in
Sweden but just check this out it's
actually pretty funny moose are pretty
gnarly don't [ __ ] around like a little
one yeah it's not a big one they will
come after you though then they kill
people so the dudes running around a
tree his friend flossing as he
videotapes them it's very dangerous
actually all right I tell to stay by the
trees me too god damn the thing is cuz I
was gonna kill you they will they will
um nothing's out the truck is friend
yeah I'm moose well I'm travel you I
thought you got that little one yeah I'm
with the show in Utah where where my
parents live they did the first thing
times be very careful of the moose if
you see them especially a female get the
[ __ ] away and what about the males with
the big yes I don't know but I mean
moose do kill people yeah yeah the super
yeah there's a video over aggressive
very aggressive if they feel like you're
you know encroaching on her and their
babies or whatever here we are so big I
again I saw the moose that hangs around
my parents house the thing is like it's
so big it gets it's bigger than a horse
yeah yeah they hung those there's a
video on online of a guy who's on his
snowmobile and a moose is trying to
attack him and he he ended up having to
pull his gun out and shoot it on a
pistol he shot it like I'm about yeah
just is a hard one I really owe him yeah
but he shot it in the head you know is
like a good good thing was right in his
face but he had to do it but Steve
Rinella our our buddy who I've been
hunting with three times
Steve got attacked by a moose
they'll [ __ ] him up yeah man ripped his
jeans in half like just got him with the
old horns like good news its wishes or
horns are like you know they are there
they're enormous there - ient I like it
nice moves man yeah I don't want to [ __ ]
there's that picture of Rogan carrying
bring up the picture of Rogan on the
cover of muscle and fitness
look at how big the leg is Rodin's
carrying it's a leg no muscle fitness
yeah look at how big this is right there
it's a muscle fit what's up hunting are
us I'm seeing look at that look at how
big that leg is on on Rogen's how cool
is you look at muscle fitness
you mean Peterson's hunting I meant F it
is nothing uh yeah that's I meant
nothing that leg is though look at how
big that legs that's a cool picture
though yeah picture I heard moose are
responsible for the most deaths like by
an animal in Canada look I believe that
they're over aggressive man yeah he's
anyone look at that leg that kicks him
he'll run yeah don't mess around so see
how he's dead serious yeah look I wish I
was in the background of Crowley good
hmm holding the rest of them it's just
sad I like moose meat Brennan I do too
I mean it's meat for the year you know
and it tastes a lot like elk so says
Brian who hasn't had close I've asked I
asked him you got a friend I answer open
what it tastes like I was gonna let it
slide but you gotta come free gotta
close to go to I don't believe I've
eaten moose you guys have finally if I
know I haven't
Donald Trump is on Twitter so when I
coach in the video he posted a an older
like WWE thing that you did any put
cnn's yeah let's watch it for a second
Billy I saw this and
so he's attacking a CNN seed I think
this is mondo everybody's like it's
violence against journalists and but I
think it's goodies the president is just
freakin weird his we're so he's weird I
can't get it but if you're gonna get
back at to me that's that's a sense of
humor
to me I actually of all his tweets that
I and I have I'm a critic of Donald
Trump I don't mind that because that
kind of cracked me up at least he's got
a sense of humor about it he hate
watches CNN CNN is relentless about it
where I don't what I don't like is him
talking about Mika Brzezinski who's had
very serious journalists and a hell of a
journalist and talking about how she was
bleeding everywhere from a facelift
that's not nice dude but also gentlemen
leave it yeah why don't you have enough
fires to put out you can't help - Tucker
in social media tween I know I don't
want that it's not presidential no it
worries me and he's petty that way
that's that's being a petty guy it's
also not being a gentleman anything I
did usually what M might shut them
online I'll pull out no you know what
I'm out yeah I shall man yeah no it's
not shallow man and like some Alaska lit
something like that what is it
having anyway Tom Ilan yes come on go to
his Twitter Simon like I like to find
this fascinating
he let hashtag upset refugee or
something like that
shyam Louis Twitter and go to shine
interesting right here fun yes read that
you fascism powerful really read read
what he put though dear POTUS this is
from the Holocaust Museum is this plot
familiar if so gifts which role you are
providing anagram without a cure I like
this I'll even ours fascism powerful and
continuing nationalism disdain for human
rights identification of enemies as a
unifying cause in other words the press
is the enemy of the American people
supremacy of the military rampant sexism
controlled mass media yep obsession with
national security religion and
government intertwined
uh-huh corporate power protected labor
power suppressed disdain for
intellectuals and the arts that's right
I would always remind people that
anybody with glasses and Pol Pot Mouse
China it was basically killed because
they were intellectuals obsession with
crime and punishment law and order see
Duarte do art art is ethically rampant
the bony isms Rampton cronyism and
corruption
crazy.i right yes the interesting post
yeah if you are even a small hello what
history this is not surprising good good
on you at night immigrants with added
just be aware as Americans that anybody
you give power the founding fathers
where is anybody having a monopoly of
power and because they knew that men
women anybody human beings always want
as much power as they can get when
they're ruling even if they're good
people because in their mind they
believe they know it's best for you this
is my problem with the progressive
liberal movement as well and academia
they are relentless they are not
interested in persuasion and changing
mind they're interested in punishment
and power that's my problem whether you
agree with those not I stutters
fascinating well that's a better that's
a very important thing for all of us
announcing fascism was responsible and
communism for that matter but fascism
which Commons and became a form of it
was responsible for fifty million deaths
see I can welcome sub doesn't respond to
this because yes your honor Soviet
you're on social media he's a very aware
of the social media he's not a student
of history and he's not anything that
he's had and you think that he thinks
he's right interesting
he thinks he's a man like shovelin only
has one hundred nineteen thousand
followers made some [ __ ] classics he
doesn't treat a lot yeah probably not
what else you get to this is I like this
this is America this is back and forth
this is good in America we should have
good civil discourse you should disagree
with each other and have arguments just
but when you start insulting the person
that you're arguing with right so this
is a very important distinction if I say
to me if I don't agree with this woman
and I say something about your her face
or her weight
well that's me in me that's to me itself
yet it's not you're you're you're
stepping outside the bounds of civil
discourse where you're trying to solve a
problem it's ok do you disagree and I
disagree let's have a civil discourse
and try to come to maybe some middle
ground right isn't that the idea isn't
the idea to cut it even if I don't agree
we agree there's a problem we're trying
to solve but when you insult people's
family
or their face I mean man it's just and
especially from the press also when you
assault people to lack of intelligence
yet is actually your last resource of
course if you don't have really as well
as I do yeah really is
yeah like lashing out like you have no
more firepower of intellect so you go
your face was bleeding out of face to
stop dammit let's see the resident who
has a woman who's maybe 45 or 50 with
kids like [ __ ] you man
just try says the meanest things I don't
like that [ __ ] I don't like that I don't
like it well this guy's not being a man
in my opinion I know what I wanted to
ask you guys the Pacquiao fight you know
the referee came in like the ninth round
he's like the night yeah and he's like
show me something I was like I want to
protect you yeah is that normal in
boxing pretty normal it depends on the
bottom the referee to like gee I
realized the referees it's different
than main mix martial arts kind of
similar but judges and referees are
different like referees need to know the
background in the style of the boxer so
they need to know I know many pack as a
southpaw power puncher they need know
his history his background they kind of
you know obviously horns a new guys so
they need to know stuff I just don't
think they knew enough about horn it
looked like you you know they're going
to stop it so when he ah he has that
power goes yeah I'm trying to protect
you here man you're getting lit up
I don't see you taking more damage it's
good thing you didn't you know did you
think that he was again I didn't think
he was no I thought he was been a little
bit of trouble but you could have done
that in the anti Joshua fight back lit
you know verse Klitschko there's a
million fights you could see doing that
that was weird for me is watching it it
also hurts Horne because now people are
dude you must got stopped in the night
there and throw in the towel how can you
say you want right and we all every one
heard that but the referee jobs very
important and I'll get to it when I get
more in depth as the Connor and Floyd
fight gets closer but the ref and that
fight seemed a huge factor
huge huge I think I'll use a brother who
I exploited one hour super vet and puts
can be up to Floyd why uh
because in boxing you know he kind of
hit smart well in the he also you know
Showtime presentation he's in bed with
them the Commission he only fights in
Vegas in Vegas he's going to make sure
it's the ref that doesn't let Conor get
away with
thing wrong okay so you it's it's gonna
be a huge factor man and I heard that
Connors team is already saying they're
not they don't want Kenny Bayless I was
Kenny videos [ __ ] videos why yeah
he's like I don't see that I never want
to see that but we can't have we can't
have that bias nature in the ring you
don't want to see it and I supposed to
judge it or f it no we can't have that I
agree with that you can have it
good luck find a guy who's not going to
be narrow-minded as a referee in boxing
boxer D or did the dinosaurs
good luck finding out he's open-minded
three tough men it's collar versus
versus the world and when I say the
world versus the boxing world the old
boxing world including the referee the
judges well you know it's coming into to
missioning in it their sport so you know
there it is he's doing their sport and
no one won't see many wells bags they
think oh it's the end of boxing if he
does well or wins it's not relaxed no
just relax
you know I heard you're nuts what save
relaxes people off you don't say that
okay yeah they say you know when
someone's like all upset and go relax
I guess it's a trade of terms by that
try that in a relationship when you're
having an argument I relax
see what happens yeah they actually
experts say you shouldn't say relax
yeah you shouldn't I know that if I said
that's my wife when she was trying to
make a point
relax she'd be like what did you just
say to me what the [ __ ] did you just say
to me a sense relaxed realize you're the
one that are out of control
best advice I ever got or do I get out
of control the best advice I ever got
was from my dentist when I got married
he goes your dentist my dentist he goes
fire him nope best advice he goes he had
been married a long time ago I'll tell
you one thing it's one thing
learn how to fight a lot of people don't
know how to fight learn how to fight in
other words there are certain things you
just never say I'll make your life way
easier and don't be insulting it you
guys don't call each other names you can
complain don't call each other names
best advice I ever got smart because a
lot of times when you get in a
relationship men and women do [ __ ] like
this you're a [ __ ] idiot
and you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] and when
you do that we know they've done a lot
of studies you see that all the time you
do start they've done a lot of studies
where that kind of stuff is called
contempt and it creates scars yeah my
Poppa raised me right I've never
say the girl you [ __ ] idiot well your
jeez I don't know this isn't working out
here yeah I don't need a dentist on that
or site you know how people who do it
though people how they do they yeah and
they get crazy and they start calling
names ya know your job or you know don't
be a dumbass
you call me dumbest I said don't be
don't be above facts do not be there not
me and not a dumbass right you know run
use your Bradley's stupid you they were
leg you're calling me stupid I didn't
said it I'm saying that would be a
stupid thing to know that's not my
[ __ ] idiot would say you you wanna
stick with it are you kind of [ __ ] it
if you know that's when you can take it
out of that yeah but a [ __ ] idiot
would save that they're all gonna be
it's like an idiot and I'm not call
anyone it's your choice to jump into
that [ __ ] idiot here's what drives me
crazy that when somebody goes like like
start making your case watches make a
case start arguing with me what is it
what it was the problem you have with me
but you never pick up anything no wow
yeah I wasn't done talking
wow I wasn't done talking that's amazing
would you like to keep talking or what
when you're ready to hear with always go
oh [ __ ] ah that that that Wow oh you
make sure get in with your sniffing oh
they're so strange out of strange are
you not even over we had a barbecue like
4th July barbecue a bunch of people over
and there's this you know there's like
normal fourth of July [ __ ] there's
guacamole there's salsa this chip
there's your normal stuff all sudden is
full of peanut from it like the peanuts
are you correct like with the shell on
yeah one of those is peanuts here but
one thing there doesn't belong like it's
like you know it's like already and I
went why would you put peanuts on right
there baby stop freeze-frame right there
because I've done this right there i can
you can anybody would walk in and go
like this way they should freeze friends
and thing and go now make lemon juice
where Brennan should really say they
look great
instead now healthy I don't feel it
being passes me like I feel good it
doesn't make sense I went we can have
peanuts I don't think they should be in
the same order next week walk more in
salsa I think I put them over there
also the shelves in the house don't make
sense I'm sorry does this look like a
Texas Roadhouse we should throw the
peanuts on the ground I thought it looks
like me I also grew up American as [ __ ]
and we don't have peanuts at a barbecue
I'm gonna take these peanuts come
somewhere else
matter of fact should I just get rid of
the peanuts all-american barbecue I'm
not an elephant not an elephant don't
having drunk I'm sorry did we hire an
elephant why are the peanuts by the
salsa now event didn't make sense yeah
it makes no sense now how did that work
out for you yeah you know yeah not well
no I know okay not well it's just a it's
but it's like you're sure I don't like
it it's like a fourth of July barbecue
there's a symphony here
I got burgers on the grill there's
cheddar cheese there's some hot dog
Oh what's this cherry pie that makes
sense ice tea hold there salsa clock
[ __ ] yay peanuts hog well why are the
Korean ribs next to the hummus peanuts
with shells suck ass Oh was my diabetic
how's it going why are you throwing
peanuts show game you know no matter
even if you try to eat them even if NASA
had machinery and they were breaking the
kiss
there's always [ __ ] that falls on the
floor I'm sorry oh you know Dodgers game
why is your penis on the handheld Mike
would follow you around I'm a hand fire
on his handheld Mike my we got in a
fight because my wife we had a group of
people and she decided make up this is
gonna sound weird maybe he's agree with
it but she made a giant and I mean AG
ghonte salad with just lots of leafy
greens and I just knew was coming over
and I saw it your friend come over yep I
saw all this like it was all salad just
a huge salad I was like wait and that
was all year and a half there was other
stuff but I was like here's Brown salad
I know my friends and they're not going
to eat salad because it makes fun wires
me to take it put in a bowl but also you
made it way too early so now what's
going to happen to that sounds gonna
wilt it's a little hot to exhaust yeah
so we just threw away a whole bunch of
salad now I appreciate salad I'll eat
some salad when I have a party watching
the game party food it's not a party
food
nobody wants to eat out guys again I'm
already annoyed you if you're eating
salad you [ __ ] rabbit if you're at my
house and you got a big thing of salad a
big bowls out like Frank Grillo would do
because he's super healthy I'm already
good food though he has great food but
I'm already annoyed at anybody who's
eating a South need my roughage I'm like
yeah but you're at my party now so you
go ahead and get those [ __ ] lamb
chops some people who know how to throw
a party man yeah they really don't yeah
and I when we got in a fight and I knew
to keep my mind live in Calabasas Oh
into your neighbor's house worst party
I've been to oh they had no food mail
that they like hummus there's Fritos
next to it people come in they just they
don't know it's those carrots from a box
carrots or my bag and there's like some
applesauce like hungry without some
walnuts sometimes it's a symphony god
damn they're a certain thing where in
the [ __ ] did you grow up
we're barbed where it's a 4th of July
barbecue there's something that standard
man well burgers hotdogs
Doritos my baked beans even corn on the
cob maybe you want some goddamn cherry
pie some cold ones yeah outside of that
unless you're from a different country
you should not [ __ ] with that sometimes
you have somebody who's kind of new age
you have a mother who decides because I
patty her who's mom for Thanksgiving
patty just wanted a normal Thanksgiving
our mama's a real hippie and loved her
it but she she she presented to the kids
tofuku-ji debate well there was tofu and
there was a they had a duck and peas had
a duck some opinions as you like can we
just be a normal family I don't want a
[ __ ] she's like 13 I don't want a
[ __ ] duck I want to be normal for
once I want a [ __ ] 30 minutes why
can't we have a turkey why do we have to
have a subversive bird for [ __ ]
Thanksgiving to be different a duck and
some pcs I just don't get it man
there's barbecue protocol this barbecue
protocol this Thanksgiving protocol with
it yeah I don't like when on
Thanksgiving places and when somebody
presents a giant ham with those uh spicy
what are those spices you ever have that
time I like the thing is singing the top
yeah my little branches yes those
branches what are those that like a
nutmeg the other sometime
anything that I don't think is sharp
little things they put a touch to giant
ham and I'm always like that hand like I
love him I hate the end something about
that ham I don't know you know what you
know what can [ __ ] loaves clothes
clothes that's right you know can
[ __ ] kick rocks turkey I the drives
bird in the land yeah
Turkey yeah those little [ __ ] I'd
everything the bikes I was out of there
white thing right yeah it's pretty
[ __ ] white chair cannon in there Jim
uh would you like uh what do you guys do
for 4th July barbecue well it's there
for the sideshow if they're actually
Korean then I goes no no he's born in
Dallas for God no I was born in Korea
man what you lived in do you for up and
down up in Texas you think you have some
American traditions yeah same as you
guys pretty much so like were you gonna
do for your birthday I'll tell you it's
the same hot dogs hamburgers standard
[ __ ] right your family and my friends
will just do fireworks and drink your
whoa fireworks are legal sir
yeah you come to my house you probably
not gonna get hamburgers and hot dogs
you probably get steak and I'm you know
I'm a prima donna I'm like looking like
hot dogs I was on the grill sweating
yesterday 20 burgers some hot link you
thought you liked you huh oh yeah
non-stop non-stop yeah Tony came over
with his kids I was like dude how know
if I come in the Sun there because
here's why his wife is from England they
start to say our mouth shoulder those
color my shoe yeah I don't know if I'd
get mountains on heels Dale of water no
there's like two little baby hippo swim
in the water a 17 month old and a three
year old
these [ __ ] English fish who can swim
like you wouldn't believe I was a good
god man he does that right they love the
water just that you ever see that movie
powder yeah yeah just their entire bases
are covered white know I have half on
full bodysuits just white hands white
actually eats out and then all white I'm
like god damn bow cuz he put did he put
a lot of someone put a hundred proof I
went you might as when I go out I mean
have more available the sweat in like
and they had these huge hat the Sun
didn't touch these cats my son's here
when he was here like a beaten in the
Sun I got a slab of those he rose up
he's got those here how about 20 times
32 Wow he wants a boy so bad he has two
girls he's like dude I hope
the boy found it last week another girl
ah naughty girl some guys like that they
say guys with high testosterone get the
girl that's right that's right
it's parently the Delta Force guys those
high-level Special Forces guys almost
always have girls they rarely have good
I know what's going on Miss Alyssa I
mean like an evolutionary thing it is
certainly it is true but um that seems
like an evolutionary thing like you got
this ultra male they need to be softened
down so it makes sense yeah if you had
like guys like Tim Kennedy just churning
out boy after boys right yeah that kid
it'd be good be born is your offering
Harris they said like the large
proportion of UFC fighters have
daughters yeah that make sense but you
have a son that son yeah I like the you
have a lot bats now what's going on your
shoes and stuff and so now what are we
going on that with you I know I wonder
if if that's actual fact like men with
height aside I have heard that in the
statistics for rotodyne six guys and
don't forget is I don't think it was an
actual study yes my eyes I read that
there was it that the most of us kept a
cool baby hippo eyes right no no I bring
up that study chin why don't often
testosterone but it's it's um or what
else would it be well I think guys who
are in certain things I will send horses
guys hey gopis click to go back to that
article in the first line this is a
doctor fortunately a father's love of
testosterone will have little effect on
their children it's more complex than
that
yeah yeah yeah I don't that's just a
weird coin no but I think that they did
that there is some truth to guys who are
in professions high-risk professions so
like you know slavey seals or and stuff
apparently I don't know if it's that's
my father's have high risk lows and it
put special forces
have more daughters there you go I don't
know I don't think there's a big study
done I'm a tall girl that's a form I
don't know if we want to get end up
before important I don't know I don't
know if there's any scientific what is
ready to be a try again yeah I don't
think we're on Fridays or so don't want
to send us if you if there's a study
senator the finally kid and ran have two
kids on average I heard a soccer soldier
get my daughter back
they'll emails like a real thing if it's
there yeah yeah coming I think it's bro
science right now like maybe like all
real successful athletes have daughters
and push force guys have daughters just
I heard they get it I think it was in
I've heard it for years for us yeah I've
heard it for years I've never seen like
an actual study on it I see some real
[ __ ] you got to put more daughters and
you're putting just have daughters have
more daughters than sons but this I
don't think they've done a study on now
there's a have to see some shipment and
do this strapless yet chin is that it
that's pretty much yeah when I get
someone's going to send us some real
[ __ ] if it's out there for sure
those are good man gets to drop
knowledge I got of dropping knowledge um
and it's this is always gender madness
that we talk about and stuff I thought
this is fascinating in and they did this
this this comedian but she's also a
sociologist she did a documentary series
documentaries in Norway so Norway is
I'll tell you the the countries that
have the most sort of gender neutral
where where both genders are represented
the best where they have Norway yeah the
closest but so so the places where
gender is where if you're a woman you
have a it's much better for you than
otherwise right so so the the gender gap
is the most narrow okay according to all
these statistics so you have the best
access to health care you you have a
better chance of getting into politics
you have equal pay and all that stuff
those countries are I
Flint is number one Finland number two
norway number three sweden number four
take a guess as to what number five is I
thought this is fascinating so weird
wolf yeah this according to need like a
lot of different stats I couldn't
believe this it's in Africa what is it
Rwanda there's associate nobody would
then Ireland then the Philippines which
is interesting and then but there's a
lot of reasons for that and then
Slovenia and then New Zealand and
finally Nicaragua that's top ten but
what's interesting is that so in Norway
they passed a lot of legislation
including the gender Act of 1978 where
essentially they were even like kind of
making sure that you had quotas where if
you had a board you have that a certain
number of women on there and stuff and
there's a lot of that a lot of movement
in Western Europe to do this with
actually forcing you know certain boards
and things to have more women which i
think is a mistake for a lot of reasons
but either way what's interesting about
Norway's that they have such a narrow
gender gap and they've done all this
work for decades to try to bring the
gender gap together thinking that the
idea was to get more women into
engineering more men into nursing they
really tried to push men into nursing
they try to get men to stay home yeah
and guess what when what and according
this documentary and is pretty powerful
evidence because they had all kinds of
scientists do this when you allow when
you have the the genders to be really
equal what ends up happening is their
biology actually has an ability to
express itself so something like one
male to 15 nurses is the ratio in Norway
it has the opposite effect way more men
went in engineering way more men went
into high-risk jobs there are certain
biological impulses there are certain
denial on it yes that there are
biological yes this is very surprising
to a lot of the social constructionist
but there are biological differences
between men and women in our bodies and
our minds oh my god like boys take way
more risks that's why so many boys are
always in the hospital for things like
parkour and the X Games and stuff like
that and that's in the intrude that's
what else we get paid a higher side less
time yes
they work longer hours all that kind of
stuff more singularly focused and stuff
like that women yes women have longer
maternity leave but women a lot of times
this is another huge surprise guess what
a lot of women want to stay home with
their kids for a little bit longer than
men do whoo oh my god does that mean I'm
a sexist when I say that and Norway's a
classic example of kind of how when you
allow biology to take over and you close
the gender gap women go into certain
professions and men go and they're not
they don't have the same [ __ ]
interests all the time it doesn't mean
it's bad but it's actually created more
of a gender gap in many ways which is
kind of fascinating so here's the big
lesson yes you want equality of
opportunity but you should be very
careful about enforcing an equality of
outcome that's a very different thing
and a lot of social construction is a
lot of these radical left-wing
ideologues and people and stuff like
that and you know the right has its own
issues but they're they're so into kind
of trying to figure out a way to enforce
an equality of outcome you must have a
certain number of women on your board
well okay but what if that's not where
women want to be where what if for
whatever reason this job it's men are
more competent more interested more
intense about the job and so that's why
they are in that field that's what you
have to worry about just whatever the
whatever whatever the truth of the
matter is instead of enforcing it with
these laws and we're doing that and
there are people that are driving this
narrative then there's more and more of
this pressure to kind of like you know
let's get more women in there and less
enforce it let's enforce that outcome
it's a dead end it's not going to work
it doesn't work three minutes yeah it's
in our DNA let you know in countries
though there are not as developed
economically so in Egypt we're going to
see women that tend to go into
professions like engineering into
professions that are traditionally male
why because they pay more they pay more
yes they pay more so but when when money
no longer becomes as much of an issue
like in Norway and women men and women
are really free to make their own
choices you see you see biology and yeah
biology expressing
so so let biology takes place and the
narrative and colleges dude is that when
you say that there are big differences
between men and women biologically it's
taboo and if you say the stuff they're
like you that's [ __ ] this and
there's another reason for it and you're
considered a sex ester you're not
looking at the science no the science is
very clear but science is science
science shouldn't have a political
agenda attached to it and it does and it
does and we have to get away from that
[ __ ] you're not doing anybody favors
you're certainly not doing women favors
or anything else by punishing
suppressing censoring and certainly not
skewing the science to your favor or
ignoring the science stop it mmm-hmm so
there it is look at the stage a it's a
documentary it's a very interesting
backwards Norway yeah you're sick that's
all real quick
you made me think about this did you do
you guys know about Hawaii five-o that
show yeah no yes yeah so two of their
actors I guess but but do you guys watch
it at all I've watched it a couple of
times here I don't I can't yet say I
kind of they're both enacting else on TV
and literally anything else yeah baby
baby I don't I've never quit the show
after CBS refused to pay them as much as
their white co-stars but then I think
they're just pushing this race thing I
don't know if it has to do with race but
wolf the only two Asian actors like the
show didn't get equal pay as the cutter
for char's yeah and it's really white so
first of all a lot of that is based on
previous clips so a lot of these
contracts are based on what you came to
the table with like what you're curating
what value yeah man and they org invade
they negotiate a lot of the contracts
they also also know what people are
tuning into so if you know I'm never
going to get paid as much as certain
black actors because they put more butts
in the seat etc etc so Hollywood's
pretty cut-and-dry Hollywood is not
they're not I promise you also know they
wore their Asian no we're not going to
pay them as much of those a they also
know they would have a lawsuit on their
hands if they didn't have the
information back to something you know
look at the numbers they're not the same
draws Caucasian it just so happens the
Caucasian is a bigger draw they happen
to be [ __ ] white than these aids you
could go to many colleges and be like
look at all the Asians Harvard MIT musi
LA Asians
what the [ __ ] is going on man at black
people I'm not an ID am I
they're only a few what the [ __ ] is
going on you know when they when they
enforce these black quotas also in
schools too so they'll they'll they'll
sort of have a lot of black students
like at MIT and stuff what they don't
tell you is that a lot of times when
these these they'll you know the certain
quotas color quotas a lot of the black
students that they have that are the
kind of I get into MIT or whatever it
might be when they maybe should go to
another college the dropout rate is 27%
and they don't tell you about that so
anytime you try to enforce these things
and you got to be very careful about
equality of outcome equality of
opportunity yes equality of outcome be
very careful trying to artificially
engineer that yeah that's my problem
with the left-wing with this you know
the the studio trust me has the fact of
reason why not PMS this is surprising
that's a big that's a big show oh yeah
well and I wonder what what's really
going on there but you know this is also
actors I've been there I know exactly
how much certain people are making I'm
like there's a reason for the feeling
with fighters too you know you know how
much the top guys in there's a reason
he's getting that and you're not I'm
joking I'm in negotiations right now for
certain thing I'm doing and you know
it's it's cut dry you know yeah but but
after a while you can prove yourself and
you can leverage and stuff but you get a
bring you'll show your value man this is
whether it's business when I work
business 101 that's it well there we are
oh it's really surprising though I'm not
really get for them because you get it
just going somewhere I wouldn't quit but
I will say this Asians like in Hollywood
if it's not I'm not blaming white power
structure or anything else for this I
will not do that just like you again the
agents are not [ __ ] is over what I
wouldn't I was actually going to say
they should be in a business now let me
smell fish
no but but I will say that Asian you
just Marshall or move but they should
only be allowed to do martial arts
movies and speak yes Asian yes
it's a lot of Asian by the way because
the Asian can be Russia and it could be
a lot of other things no but I'm I do
think for a long time there were very
few roles for Asians and this is this is
in the 2000s I know that I know that I
mean they're they're very very few
opportunities you know China's killed in
the movie
yeah Wow signal cars in the world yeah
but let the marketplace decide let the
marketplace decide man we you know
you're going to want to watch that
those are good wife I'm gonna do tune in
CBS I don't a mission we're Asian oh man
we're in her wedding present I am NOT
watching season 17 by the way is an
actor that when you quit a job like that
you're making they're making tons your
night on tons oh good now now now hear
me out here just as a guy's been in this
business long time seen this seeing how
this movie plays out now you American
clothes I want you like do you know
their names and you know a lot of [ __ ] I
don't thank you
now you're gonna now they I'm going to
see them on auditions you're going to
see them on auditions right we're going
to go into rooms you and I you're in the
business I'm not gonna see them you're
on say let's try out for the same car
might be ah sir you know a judge you
know nation what do you do in oh you are
trying it so so now this is another
thing so now you don't see Asians only
please I mean they sometimes but these
two are being they're being submitted
for everything I'm being submitted for
right all efficiencies all ethnicities
welcome every audition breakdown says
all ethnicities welcome that means that
their agents wouldn't dream of saying
well they're only looking for a white
actor okay so now just just in Hollywood
you're back in the room you're back in
the room and you're auditioning for
parts okay now nobody's gonna say [ __ ]
but what happens if they go mental note
as five years and they might cause a
problem yeah oh yeah oh so now there's
no [ __ ] gets quiet but nobody tells you
they go this what happens writing behind
closed doors call me up and say that I
get the part a B yet the program you
know what dude they liked you they are
huge fans of you you did an amazing job
but subtext your problem your isn't yeah
they [ __ ] loves you they're going
another way but they absolutely it's
gonna be that way no line unless they
hopefully we have another plan I'm just
saying 10 years later you wake up and
you haven't worked I've seen it it's
been I hope it works out for hopefully
they're like a gig in China where I'm
not trying to please very in and she
looks like she's with this hot but no
but there's not a huge Japanese
market for movies in China it's [ __ ]
too much so they I'm sure Lika gorya has
an amazing film yeah they're killing it
mark that's why so many movies give me
an idea in Korean he might just be you
know he's from lost he's he's super fine
oh I also didn't see that I did I feel
like that guy a lot us or not yah you
know what
I know Bolton yeah no you're the rush
out I like those guys man
I'm just kidding it's ok I really like
that actor oh yeah yeah lost but he's
very hot oh yeah and she's what else -
she's she's what else she from I bet you
she I bet you she's your Asian I
guarantee she's I guarantee encourage
she's having these Heidi they're both
really very good yeah and we're seen
before
oh well we ran all there you go yeah I
hope it what's up four kids play and
Daniel day yeah shut up dinner doing Kim
Park somebody somebody was saying about
that it was really fun it early it's a
little arrogant to be like I quit acting
everyone they list yeah we're standard a
lunar we got it we have seen the guy
knows a kid but you know about it
I quit everybody I just want a hammock
Wednesday Lewis I'll show you may not
have quit my favorite actor that's actor
I he can do with everyone that's actor
work I let's wrap this [ __ ] up
sheltered a Daniel Dae Kim and Grace
Park Frazier yeah being realist can they
find you man Grace Park is correct here
you got to cram pain all right yeah
we've gone over it they're both drama
Francis I'm zoning out like our agent
all right I am going to be at the comedy
zone in Charlotte North Carolina what
dates the 20th 21st 22nd and then of
course as you know I'll be in MO high ad
lib uh just is just a lot of Laughs
comedy fest
I will not be it just for laughs and
Brian is going to be a little Brian
still going and then on my Long Beach
date this is out of my control out of my
hands they have to reschedule it it's do
as a promoter
it's due to the laughs acting I
literally have nothing do with this it's
not that skin cancelled they're just
rescheduling it that's the only news I
have on they don't tell me why I know I
don't deal with any of it don't be mad
at me but Long Beach I'm not going to be
hanging to just reschedule it and I will
be in you know a lot of them it's uh
July is busy isn't it be it's an
individualized a little money seven
a little bit money in 29th and 30th you
are going to be let's see I July 20th
I'm in Phoenix I'm in Salt Lake City on
the 21st both of those sold shows are
almost sold out then on July 27th I'm in
Toronto 28th I'm in Milwaukee 29th I'm
in Chicago Detroit on the 30th so it
goes Phoenix Salt Lake City Toronto
Milwaukee Chicago Detroit and then
Wednesday I announce the date and times
for Dublin in London big brown is coming
live tea fat K calm for Brian's tickets
tea vodka calm for my tickets get him
get him home this is the finally kid
brow